since joe biden took office america
seems to be bouncing from one crisis to
the next you've got the kobat 19
pandemic massive inflation afghanistan
russia invades ukraine the energy crisis
yet all along the way it's the little
guys us who seem to get screwed the most
you know the have-nots in society
why are we always left holding the bag
after all the connected halves do all
the damage
the haves are the power broker elites
who seem to make the rules the rest of
us are forced to live under
this kind of got me thinking that sounds
an awful lot like an oligarchy doesn't
it let's check the definition of an
oligarchy
courtney merriam-webster an oligarchy is
quote a government in which a small
group exercises control
especially for corrupt and selfish
purposes ding ding you win win a winner
chicken dinner are we already living
under an oligarchy now
are we being governed by a small group
of powerful elites who make special
rules for themselves you know the haves
while making a separate set of rules for
everyone else you know us the have-nots
i've got some evidence that may help us
answer this question right here
so just this week the president of
blackrock no doubt i have that's one of
the largest investment firms in the u.s
was quoted in bloomberg talking about
the have-nots us saying quote oh this is
a gem
for the first time this generation is
going to go into a store and not be able
to get what they want
and we have a very entitled generation
that has never had a sacrifice really
yeah i want to ask some of those iraq
vets who came home without limbs about
that
so to be clear he thinks you're entitled
for not wanting to pay ten dollars for
gas or deal with food shortages
you see he has no problem at all you
know blackrock guy playing ten dollars a
gallon for gas he's one of the hops not
going to suffer at all probably doesn't
even know how much he pays for gas
here's more evidence just a few weeks
ago new york city lifted the vaccine
mandate for all performers
giving unvaccinated professional
athletes the green light to play home
games again
but what if you're a dirt under the
fingernail city worker or a heroic
firefighter or police officer who's been
forced out of a job because of the
mandate
well clearly you're have not
at this time we are not
reviewing if we're going to bring back
those a large number was they were hired
with the understanding they had to be
vaccinated we're going to focus on the
science
what's going we're going to do what's
right and we're going to make sure we
we're healthy
and being healthy
is not only physically healthy it's
economically healthy you may consider it
as a double standard i i consider the
analysis that i made and i'm comfortable
with my decision
yeah i can't take these guys you see
folks people like mayor adams and these
pro athletes you know they're all the
haves
yet the police officers making 55 60 000
a year who are now unemployed they're
clearly you know the have-nots
and what about the teachers unions who
were just you know looking out for the
kids safety during coveter so they said
a new report shows that teachers unions
work closely with the cdc to determine
when they thought it was going to be
safe for kids to go back to school
they've never been involved to this
degree in this decision in the past
sounds like a kind of a group of
connected habs to me right can you call
up the cdc and do that i don't think so
and what if you live in chicago and
you're concerned about rising crime ah
too bad you're a have not shut your
mouth
you and the rest of the have-nots you
better just you know find a way to deal
with it
but don't sweat it
if you're one of the haves like chicago
mayor lori lightfoot
she's reportedly protected by a special
security squad of dozens of police
officers
crime problem doesn't affect her what's
she worried about
then there's all the haves in congress
you know the zeroes who were supposed to
serve as our representatives
led by the way by the disgraceful nancy
pelosi well here's a list of everything
they're beholden to uh not beholden to
i'm sorry i mean exempt from sorry it's
a slip there if you're a member of
congress and you don't want to get the
vaccine don't worry you want to be able
to trade in the stock market regardless
of the fact that you control all the
legislation that basically impacts the
markets go for it
you don't want to show up for work you
want to vote remotely even though the
pandemic is largely over
no
problem
you don't want to use obamacare either
for your family while we have to you
don't have to you're a have
so what are the haves on capitol hill
actually accomplishing for us you know
the have-nots
remember their vote to print trillions
of stimulus dollars to help boost the
economy supposedly help us during the
pandemic well check out this headline
this is how much it helped us
we all now face an inflation tax because
they printed a boatload of monopoly
money of fifty two hundred dollars a
year please stop helping
turns out the have-nots are paying the
bill again after the haves voted to
print all that money but listen don't
misunderstand right
while their actions cost you more you
know these powerful elites like hunter
biden they're doing a-okay
making millions on their corruption
this isn't russian disinformation
these are hard facts backed up by bank
records so a company that was
effectively an arm of the chinese
government transferred one million
dollars in november 2017
to accompany that hunter biden is
managing
and has invested in
and in case you were under the mistaken
disbelief that this is only happening in
the united states let me disabuse you of
that now the have-nots in germany their
citizens right now are bracing for yeah
electricity blackouts due to natural gas
rationing because the haves in germany a
while ago coming around a little bit now
but they decided to stay dependent on
russian energy
and it isn't like we weren't warned
about this either this problem was
coming everybody knew check out this
report from cbs four years ago
germany is totally controlled by russia
president trump confirmed europe's worst
pre-summit fears by using the nato stage
to criticize allies blasting germany
over a natural gas pipeline deal with
russia it's very
sad when germany makes a massive oil and
gas deal with russia
where you're supposed to be guarding
against russia and germany goes out and
pays billions and billions of dollars a
year to russia german officials deny
that the controversial nordstream 2
pipeline will allow russia to exert
undue influence over their country and
for anyone out there by the way still
doubting that this isn't on purpose to
bring a new order to the world or
whatever they want to call it this was
just a little bit ago at the world
government summit
the title
of this session
are we ready for a new
world order
are you ready but i'm not this new world
order really sounds like crap to me it
sounds like it really sucks so how's
this working out for you enjoying living
under the rules put in place by the
house working out great isn't it i guess
it doesn't really matter what we think i
mean you know we are the have-nots hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else